welcome to 2023 hope everybody had a
good New Year we're going to start today
by talking about the new Heroes of many
young men I'm talking about people like
of course Jordan Peterson but more
recently Andrew Tate this guy who goes
by the name liver King and some of the
other folks in this universe you know
many of you emailed me about Andrew Tate
being arrested in Europe I don't really
have anything to say about his arrest
it's a law enforcement matter I don't
know if Greta tunberg's tweet was part
of what ultimately got him arrested
because of a pizza box indicating where
he was I don't know about any I don't
have any commentary about any of that
but I do think it's time that I talk a
little bit more
about the Andrew Tates plural right
these figures like Andrew Tate and some
of the right-wing political commentators
are in that group in a particular way
certainly Jordan Peterson you know I'm
including liver King in this and some of
the uh Tick Tock uh uh uh workout and
supplement type influencers because what
they really are are scamming people
mostly young men and it is very sad to
see and maybe we can talk about it a
little bit and maybe break somebody out
of it or at least get somebody to
reconsider what they've fallen for so
let's explain what's going on uh these
folks Andrew Tate Peterson liver King
Etc
there are just a few examples of people
who have become popular
to make it really simple to simplify why
they've become popular they appeal to
young men
who feel victimized sometimes
underrepresented in mainstream culture
and Society
disadvantaged certainly dissatisfied
with either their level of success their
amount of muscle their physique when it
comes to like the liver Kings their job
success their success with women
do some older men follow these guys yeah
do some women follow these guys sure but
if you go to a Jordan Peterson event or
you see who follows Andrew Tate or liver
King it's mostly men and they're mostly
relatively young now there's nothing
wrong with that in principle that's not
the point I'm making there's all sorts
of different people whose followers are
concentrated among some demographics and
not others that's not the problem that's
the context these types like the Tates
and the Petersons Etc
they offer a message that is of freedom
of Liberty
of men taking control of their lives and
fighting back against a culture or
society that is putting them down
everything about culture and Society is
helping others it's either helping women
or it's helping people who are already
wealthy or whatever right but the thing
about it is that when you look more
closely at the message you find that the
disappointments they address the
Grievances they speak to
these are standard ones in the
prototypical
self-help uh discourse just completely
standard nothing unique about it and and
specifically many of them are actually
tailored to young men I've said before
Jordan Peterson's advice is almost
completely Universal it's been done a
thousand times and that's okay what
Jordan Peterson does is he packages it
in a particular way the personality of
Peterson the demeanor the stuff
surrounding it is somewhat different and
unique to a degree
and so they take those obstacles or
those problems they combine it with
their own delusions of grandeur and
sense of how powerful they themselves
are and also the victimhood framing
we're victims so are you I'll teach you
to overcome this this victimization that
you're suffering from now they're all a
slightly different brand or category
with Jordan Peterson it's more cultural
and societal well I'm going to help you
overcome the social and societal and
cultural issues that are holding you
down with Andrew Tate it's more overtly
about how to get women and make money in
business and then with liver King it's
how to get muscular and live this
ancestral Primal lifestyle which is
completely absurd by the way but not the
subject of this particular video so it's
versions of the exact same thing the
really funny thing or maybe it's the sad
thing or maybe it's the ironic thing is
the Revolutionary self-framing that
these guys do when you listen closely it
almost sounds like Marxist rhetoric
except it's the epitome of grifter
capitalism and I'll explain exactly what
I mean by that when you listen to
Peterson or Tate or or liver King and
these others they sort of talk like they
are the Marxist leaders who are going to
fire everybody up they're gonna red pill
you
and you're finally going to overthrow
your oppressors the capitalist like that
but that's in Marxism except they are
actually the capitalists they've simply
adapted a rhetoric
and it's actually working really really
well liver King it's totally overt the
capitalist grift is over he's selling
supplements it's unclear liver King even
takes his supplements he previously
claimed to eat insane amounts of raw
animal organs every day some emails that
leaked exposed that liver King doesn't
really eat much of those organs at all
it's all a capitalist grift to sell
supplements okay with Jordan Peterson
it's he sells books and um does personal
appearances you know speaking gigs at
which he gets paid and the language is
more about take control of your life
take control of it don't don't let uh
don't don't let the leftists suppress
you don't let those who want to compel
speech oppress you don't let big Tech
oppress you or whatever the case may be
and with Andrew Tate it's you know he's
got his courses his subscription program
where he'll teach you to meet women and
make money and this sort of thing they
are packaging almost Marxist
revolutionary sounding rhetoric
with this I will give you the red pill I
I can show you the reality of reality
in this super capitalist grifter
situation now this phenomenon is not
limited to three these three guys by any
means a lot of the self-proclaimed gurus
who offer quick fixes easy solutions to
complex problems they it's the same type
of thing they are preying on people who
are sometimes desperate
often vulnerable
and they promise them whatever they need
to promise them they don't really
deliver much other than a false and
sometimes temporary sense of empowerment
and yet they continue to do really well
in our society and culture people are
drawn to them and drawn to the Allure of
the easy fix now some of them have
become more sophisticated
so they they tell you I'm not going to
give you an easy fix they've
Incorporated this is like there's an
iterative process with this stuff where
first it's overtly an easy fix and then
you have the second level charlatans who
go listen uh I'm not here to offer you
an easy fix it's it's not a One-Stop
shop but it's still this sort of very
prescribed methodology that is still the
idea of the easy fix which they tell you
will be difficult but it's still here's
the solution here's the solution and at
the end of the day what you have is
those who come to you and say
step outside of the bubble I will tell
you the real nature of reality and tell
you how to take control of it they are
actually the ones suffering from you
staying in a very bump in in a similar
bubble to the one they claim to be
getting you out of that's really the
scam and the grift and you can apply it
to all of these guys and more you know
to some degree like Deepak Chopra
although he's not as popular now it's a
slightly different version of it same
type of thing that's what's going on
with these guys I would love to prevent
people from falling for it in the first
place and if they do it would be great
to get them out but that's fundamentally
what it is that these folks are selling
and remember they are selling you
something
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below